[Music]
flying over rocking state where the UN
says textbook ethnic cleansing led to
the displacement of hundreds of
thousands of her hinges Britain's new
foreign secretary was the guest of the
Burmese regime controlling Jeremy Hunt
and what he was told because they have a
very good Network they inform them said
you know if you don't clean you will
most likely be killed by the ring you
fled because of terrorists on their own
side the Foreign Secretary was told not
pickers of mass rape arson and massacres
by the Burmese military as was
documented by Sky News and others at the
time Burma is also being condemned for
the Sham trial of two Reuters
journalists jailed for investigating and
reporting massacres ibraheemís Burma's
leader a Nobel Prize winner on San Suchi
has defended their conviction despite
her own years behind bars Jeremy Hunt
raised their case and the plight of her
hing is with her but said he believes
she has little control over the military
critics say that's naive the Foreign
Secretary was sounding tougher about
bringing those behind the ethnic
cleansing to justice we need to see
action and if there isn't accountability
through any internal burmese process the
world will not let it rest at that we
will use all the tools at our disposal
to try and make sure there is
accountability because without that that
can't be a solution to the refugee
problem but that has disappointed
campaigners if it's left to Burma to
investigate itself they say justice will
never come there's no possibility for
justice in the domestic situation in
Burma the judiciary is under the control
of the military the military are
completely unaccountable and have
enjoyed impunity for decades that's why
we need to see a stop to any any support
for this judicious judicial process in
Burma
it must be an international process
through the ICC Jeremy Hunt did meet
former political
unlike his predecessors but elsewhere
officials put on a show
presenting him with smiling compliant
villagers campaigners say he needs to
see beyond that and use his new role to
bring the country's regime to account
Dominic Waghorn Sky News